- What I thought we'd do
to kind of like, you know,
kind of liven you up right at the top
is find out what you guys
would like to hear a rap about
and then I'm gonna do a rap about it.
And yeah, you bought your tickets
and we can lock that door,
(audience laughing)
so this is what's happening.
Everyone think of a
word, topic, or phrase.
We'll divide the room up into segments,
we'll get five suggestions.
If you are in the first three rows,
what would you like a rap about?
(audience speaking indistinctly)
Okay. (chuckling)
(audience laughing)
The rest of the audience
has completely tuned out
at this point, which is
probably a good thing
because the front two rows
combined have come up with,
"The day in the life
of a transgender eunuch
in Staten Island."
(audience laughing)
Yeah, that's your
responsibility, second row.
Okay.
(audience chattering)
(audience member shushing)
Guys on this side, you had a
real in-depth conversation.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Woman] Do you wanna know?
- I would love to know,
that's why I'm asking the question.
(audience member laughing loudly)
- [Woman] Inspired by all of you guys,
"High school friends that
swing", like, that, that,
what is it? Swing?
- High school friends that, that--
- [Woman] The swingers!
Swinger high schoolers.
- So like--
- [Woman] You know, the people
in the same friend group
and they switch boyfriends
and girlfriends?
- Oh! Swingers, yes.
- [Woman] Yeah!
- High school swingers.
- [Woman] That lived in Utah!
- (chuckling) Okay, great.
(audience laughing)
You can't see what it,
where every time you talk,
you emphasize with like,
that flick; it's amazing.
Just like, "I'll have the eggs! Yeah."
(audience laughing)
So people, people on this
side, but at the back,
what would you like a rap about?
Yes.
- [Woman 2] My phrase is,
"I am the leader of an
online cannibal forum."
- (chuckling) I am a leader
of an online cannibal forum,
high school swingers,
a transgender eunuch in Staten Island.
And let's come to the kind of middle,
(audience laughing)
the middle of this side,
what would you like a rap about?
(audience chattering)
- [Woman 3] Oh, ours is...
Ours is, "A model in the metaverse."
- "A Model in the metaverse."
Thank you very much, thank you.
And then we'll come to
the back of the room,
what would you guys like a rap about?
- [Woman 4] Losing your virginity!
- [Woman 5] Ethical non-monogamy.
- Okay, so I heard "losing your virginity"
and then, but what did
you say at the back?
- [Woman 5] Ethical non-monogamy.
- Ethical non-monogamy. (chuckling)
Okay.
Yeah, I feel like we're in Brooklyn
with all these suggestions, this is wild.
Okay, so... (chuckling)
if I may have your
attention class, thank you.
The suggestions are; (laughing)
a transgender eunuch in Staten Island,
ethical non-monogamy and
losing your virginity, maybe,
high school swingers, a
model in the metaverse,
and the one from over here was, your one,
which was the leader of
an online cannibal forum.
Okay.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, those are some great suggestions.
(audience chattering)
And this, lovely people, is
gonna be a freestyle rap.
That's a rap made up on
the spot based entirely
on those suggestions and do not worry,
it will not be anywhere near
as atrociously, embarrassingly,
and totally bad as you're
expecting a privately-educated,
middle-class white boy to be.
If we can drop that beat, good sir.
Let's have some fun, nice.
And you'll know the beat.
(50 Cent's "Candy Shop" beat playing)
♪ Jump on the beat then I get it ♪
♪ Let me log on the line ♪
♪ Log into the Reddit ♪
♪ Check it out ♪
♪ It's what I'm talking about ♪
♪ I could run a whole
community out of my house ♪
♪ In my bedroom me and my best mate ♪
♪ Cannibal 69 yeah
align with those dates ♪
♪ People like oh I'm assuming ♪
♪ Cannibals love to eat
the flesh of the human ♪
♪ That's true it's how we do ♪
♪ If you step too close
then I consume you ♪
♪ Take a knife and fork no need to talk ♪
♪ I just stab it til your
eye's out on stalks ♪
♪ And then I post pictures
posts some memes ♪
♪ I like everybody logging
on subscribe to me. ♪
♪ On my screen they're
like we love you dude ♪
♪ You run the forum put
the video on YouTube ♪
♪ If I look tasty might befriend ya ♪
♪ Take you out to Staten
Island transgender ♪
♪ But let me look at this ♪
♪ Never so appalled ♪
♪ Transgender but no genitals
cause you're a eunuch ♪
♪ It means they're removing balls ♪
♪ If you've seen Game of Thrones
it makes sense to y'all ♪
♪ Yeah Varys he ain't
got nothing down there ♪
♪ Staten Island a good area ♪
♪ Nah probably is kind of
tough never even been ♪
♪ Moving over here
feeling kind of obscene ♪
♪ But I get knocked down
censored on Facebook ♪
♪ They want to distract
us don't want us to look ♪
♪ They're like hi I'm Mark ♪
♪ We're tryna do better ♪
♪ We'll rename our company
now we're called meta ♪
♪ Oh did that take the bad news away ♪
♪ Ooh look at the model
and how she's a chaise ♪
♪ Got nice breasts got nice bum ♪
♪ In the metaverse you can meet everyone ♪
♪ You put VR headsets and walk around ♪
♪ You're like oh a model
that I have found ♪
♪ It compounds my sadness
compounds my fear ♪
♪ If I'm in a high school
wanna get out of here ♪
♪ My girlfriend and my boys around ♪
♪ We take 'em out to the
prom then we switch around ♪
♪ We're like you go with
Jen I'll go with Jade ♪
♪ Talk up meet up at the end of the day ♪
♪ Put our little Pocky's
in a mixing bowl ♪
♪ Then I'll pull it out
which one's that I hold ♪
♪ Oh this is Oliver's
ah who gives a fuck ♪
♪ We'll go to the car he owns a truck ♪
♪ Could start mixing it up like swinging ♪
♪ I don't like Oliver's
girlfriend cause she's minging ♪
♪ But that's fine by the way
my age in the rap I'm 16 ♪
♪ So lose virginity at
the backseat of the car ♪
♪ Do I feel nervous yeah
premature ejaculation ♪
♪ It happens a lot when
it's your first time ♪
♪ My girlfriend yeah she
really doesn't mind ♪
♪ She doesn't get upset
doesn't stop in front of me ♪
♪ Cause we practice ethical non-monogamy ♪
♪ It's when you're polyamorous
you don't give a fuck ♪
♪ Morality and ethics
yeah throw them out ♪
♪ I don't need that I just
send her a text like ♪
♪ Hey do you mind if I go and have sex ♪
♪ With someone that I've
never met before no danger ♪
♪ She's like sure Chris
you can fuck any stranger ♪
♪ And I'll be like dope
so I go and find 'em ♪
♪ And fuck the transgender
you know from Staten island ♪
(audience cheering wildly)
(50 Cent's "Candy Shop" beat playing)
(audience clapping)